shows us all she's ever used
to light up her house a bottle kerosene
lump
she lives in a village two hours drive
north of addis ababa
we have many health problems we spend
more time than we should in hospitals
and i think it's linked to this lamp
next door her brother-in-law is using
solar energy
but only he and a few others here can
afford it
women travel far with their donkeys to
get the most basic support
if we had electricity in our village
then they wouldn't have to go
far to grind maize for example
up to 65 million ethiopians that's more
than half the population are not
connected to the electricity grid
many have bought government bonds for
the construction of the grand
renaissance dom
africa's largest hydroelectric dam about
250 ethiopians live in this village
they're poor farmers who raised a
thousand
five hundred dollars for the
construction of the dumb
they're passionate about the project and
eagerly waiting
to be connected to the grid ethiopia has
started filling the dam for a second
time
and this is causing a knees downstream
egypt and sudan
are worried about how it could affect
their own water flows
the two countries want a binding
agreement governing how the dam will be
operated
talks mediated by the african union have
failed prime minister abi ahmed
recently told parliament the project
will not stop
ethiopia ethiopia does not intend to arm
other countries
our intention is to work with other
countries and improve our status
moses attempt is worried about the
tensions he has invested about two
million dollars
in expanding his oxygen and nitrogen
energy plant
in anticipation of more reliable
electricity
his factory which supplies oxygen to all
of eastern ethiopia
is facing daily unpredictable power cuts
for ethiopia is life and death
because without electricity enough
electricity this country cannot progress
at all
so being such
important commodity for us
we are contributing willingly from our
pocket
all without an agreement the completion
of the dam is imminent
and ethiopians like tishometidese his
family and neighbors
back in misraki village are preparing
for what it may bring
catherine soy al jazeera miss rock
ethiopia